el presidente de donald trump ha
participado en un acto de campaña de la
organización en latinos for trump en
miami con este evento el mandatario
quiere asegurarse el voto de los
hispanos especialmente de los
venezolanos y los cubanos en florida un
estado clave y que podría ser decisivo
para las próximas elecciones los
asistentes la mayoría de ellos hispanos
han defendido las políticas de trans
sobre economía e inmigración diciendo
que es necesario que haya una línea dura
para evitar la migración ilegal
especialmente en estos momentos en los
que consideran que se ha de preservar el
empleo de los estadounidenses tras la
pandemia de el coronavirus el candidato
republicano ha sacado pecho y ha
asegurado que el país está mejor que
nunca en términos económicos también
para la comunidad latina se ha
vanagloriado del trabajo que ha hecho
desde el despacho oval diciendo que él
ha hecho mucho más en 4 años que yo byd
en su contrincante demócrata en 47 años
en cargos públicos con todo también ha
mostrado el respaldo a los pueblos de
cuba nicaragua y venezuela y se ha
comprometido a seguir trabajando para
conseguir ha dicho que esos países
logren la libertad
habían muchos rumores de que el
presidente trump podría anunciar su
nominada a jueza de la corte suprema que
ya dijo que iba a ser una mujer pues
bien barbara lago a una cuba am en una
cubano americana de gran trayectoria
suena con mucha fuerza muchos expertos
avisan que su nominación podría ser un
guiño del mandatario a la comunidad
hispana